in 1994 a young Wall Street hotshot
named Jeff Bezos was at a crossroads in
his career continued amassing a small
fortune or abandoned it all to sell
books that decision would
single-handedly change the history of
e-commerce publishing film TV journalism
and quite possibly interstellar travel
that decision also represents a
recurring theme in his life never
settled ever this is how Jeff Bezos took
a simple idea into a garage and built
one of the largest market places on the
planet Jeff Bezos was born on January 12
1964 as a child he turned his parents
garage into a laboratory for his
inventions in his 1982 valedictorian
speech he discussed colonizing outer
space and turning earth into a giant
Nature Preserve graduating from
Princeton with a computer science degree
instead of going straight into tech he
had other ideas become a billionaire
unless you have this insatiable desire
to accrue wealth and power but I think
he just looks at it in a way that's
really different to almost anyone else I
follow that's Tom Metcalf I'm a
billionaire reporter for Bloomberg News
you know he's always driven by success
and Wall Street was the pinnacle for
most graduates he was a very
mathematical graduate I resented his
almost quant
like Outlook he quickly made a name for
himself at 26 the youngest ever vice
president of Bankers Trust Company at 28
the youngest ever senior vice president
of de Xiang Co it was there that he
discovered a giant untapped resource the
internet always time it's only never
seen such a great opportunity he went
through a wholeness industry and if you
think about ebooks easy to package hard
to damage and of course the internet
offers an infinite library de sha did
not share his optimism for the
opportunity of a lifetime
Bezos would have to leave Wall Street
whatever it is that you want to do
there's gonna be risk in your life and
risk is a necessary
ponent of progress it quite simply pet
to stuff up drove across the country and
you know the legend owes that while in
the car he was writing the business
plans setting up shop in his garage in
1994 he incorporated his book company
under the name Cadabra it wasn't great
when a lawyer misheard it as Kidada be
ultimately landed on Amazon there's a
couple of reasons specially than the
name beginning today I'd like to be on
tour with anything alphabet or a web
search we kind of like the fact it kind
of tied in with working large River and
he was spelling it plans to make Amazon
the world's largest company launching in
July 1995 a bell was installed to ring
every time a book was sold in its first
month Amazon sold to people in all 50
states in 45 different countries the
Bell was gone in weeks by September 1995
Amazon processed twenty thousand dollars
in monthly sales with its 1997 IPO
Amazon was valued at four hundred
million dollars by 1999 Jeff Bezos was
worth ten billion dollars and was times
Man of the Year
but soon after the.com crash had people
skeptical was Amazon a sustainable
business or with the bubble burst
I think anyone who knows me very
charismatic and very convincing in terms
of the long term vision he had mapped
out a decade whatever happen in the
short term he wasn't going to change
that plan I think he conveyed that
pretty well to his stockholders with the
crash eliminating many competitors
Amazon's strengthened its grip on the
market and expanded beyond books the
Kindle Alexa Amazon Studios and of
course an Amazon Prime what it does is
really lock people into the Amazon
ecosystem they're much more inclined to
be buying a lot more word of mouth
spread and that has been the biggest
driver of Amazon's
incredible revenue growth yet
historically Amazon has seen modest
annual profits an enormous amount of
cash flowing through the company yet and
what bezels does is he's not returning
that shareholder he's reinvesting that
in the company too sure and its core
businesses but also going off for these
almost moonshot projects like
Blue Origin is millions of people living
and working in space this is such a
game-changer Amazon to buy whole food
Jeff Bezos is now the richest person in
the world and fifty million dollars for
the storied Washington Post his
acquisition of the Washington Post not
only raised eyebrows but put him at odds
with another well-known billionaire he
bought the Washington Post to have
political influence if I become
president oh do they have problems
they're going to have such problem these
are some company is different to
emphasize can get Trump is pretty
reactionary you know kind of emotional
is normally doesn't really respond so
one he did suggest to be willing to send
the capability is there few businessmen
choose to make an enemy of a president
but having built an empire out of a
garage Jeff Bezos has proven capable of
handling any adversary especially
complacency
you